[Musique]
face à la première
bienvenue dans notre émission face à la
première diffusée le vendredi après midi
sur notre site internet ainsi qu'un
radio le dimanche à 12 heures réparer le
crime de l' esclavage pourquoi comment
et quand c'est le thème de notre
émission de la semaine pour en parler je
reçois pour vos tout d'abord gabriel
prive un bon jour alain privat et myriam
est malsain bonjour la malsain il était
on note évidemment et qui sont toutes
deux mal un prix 20 à damas un membre
militante du conseil national pour les
réparations le cnr et donc nous allons
parler donc du saignant ce qui l'est par
rapport aux mire le mouvement
international pour les réparations des
organisations voisine j'allais toujours
aussi en cuisine et pourquoi je vous
invite aujourd'hui parce que dans
quelques jours le 23 avril
vous allez organiser un voyage vers
l'île de gorée au large du sénégal qui a
été l'une des plateformes sur la côte
ouest africaine de la traite négrière et
de la mise en esclavage de captiver
africains déportés donc vers les
amériques au sens large du terme entre
le 15e et le xviiie siècle alors tout
d'abord justement où en est ce voyage
ym il a été rapporté que il n'ya plus de
places libres en tout cas pour cette
année madame alsa oui tout à fait je
confirme
alors ce voyage est organisé par le
mouvement international pour les
réparations
il s'agit de voyages en fait de
reconnexion avec la terre mère donc ce
voyage s'inscrit dans une démarche qui
n'est pas nouvelle en fait puisque il ya
déjà eu des échanges avec gorée
d'ailleurs il ya eu un premier voyage en
1998 qui étaient effectués par des
jeunes martiniquais européen et
sénégalais par bateau donc ils sont
partis donc le groupe de martiniquais
européens sont partis de nantes sur un
ancien chalutier qui était aménagé
points et donc ils ont rejoint le groupe
gorée et donc ils ont fait la traversée
triangulaire donc l'autre sens donc dans
le sens donc europe sénégal et
martinique donc dans le sens nord donc
c'était une première expérience je vais
bien une première expérience qui donc
voila et qui s'est ensuite 2000 qui
aboutit donc un jumelage entre la ville
de gorée et la ville de sainte-anne
puisque c'est monsieur malsain 1,5 était
donc à l'initiative de cette action qui
était à l'époque maire de sainte anne et
ensuite donc le mis en mouvement
international pour les réparations a
repris toute cette démarche là et dans
le cadre de son premier convoi donc
invité le conservateur de la maison des
esclaves de gorée il y avait également
le maire de gorée qui étaient présents
donc on voit bien que dont 98 2018
donc on retourne à gorée et c'est vrai
que ouvert voilà il est temps après donc
est-ce que vous avez l'impression mais
nous allons gérons gôniots viendront
durant la débâcle ici en martinique
gabriel privat que la vice présidente du
cdr va vous voulez répression la
conviction que les esprits ont évolué
que les mentalités ont changé quand on
parle de réparation quand on parle de
réhabilitation de nos ancêtres venant
d'afrique puisque nous avons des
ancêtres qui viennent d'ailleurs certes
mais la base d'un du peuplement de la
caraïbe et de l'arctique vient les côtes
ouest africaines
alors c'est un combat ce sont des idées
qui progressant qui progressent alors
que l'émission c'est vrai que c'est un
combat de tous les jours parce que ça
fait quand même depuis la loi de 2001 de
taubira qu'on annonce que toute la loi
est sorti comme étant
l'esclavagé crimes contre l'humanité
nous étions déjà à ce moment là le
convoi a commencé donc on va commencer à
cette époque là est donc au fur et à
mesure chaque année on a vu
effectivement grossir le rang des
participants
il ya eu les colocs avec des invités de
choix des invités des intellectuels le
panafricaniste qui venait effectivement
expliqué tous les enjeux et donc au fur
et à mesure on voit au gré c'est cette
idée de réparations il cette idée de de
l'africanité dans les esprits alors
pourquoi vous bien situer votre
organisation le seigneur ainsi que le
mien c'est vous qui organisait chaque
année le convoi pour la réparation
depuis il y aura ce sera la 18e édition
on ne fait pas tellement mais tellement
2018 voilà lemire et donc si les
mentalités ont évolué les esprits ont un
peu sont un peu mieux informés disant
est ce que pour autant cela signifie que
la population martiniquaise font en
général toutes générations comprise
adhèrent à cette idée de la nécessaire
réparation des conséquences de
l'esclavagé et de la traite négrière
il ya mal ça moi je pense que oui parce
que bon pour d'ailleurs il ya eu il ya
eu un sondage qui avait été fait par le
cran à l'époque et ses tentatives les
associations kim qui montraient que ben
plus de la moitié de
des antillais et est donc d'accord avec
cette question là donc oui les choses
évoluent évolué et on voit bien que par
rapport parce que c'était peut-être
aussi en termes très vagues pour les
gens la question des réparations
effectivement on rentre un peu plus dans
les modalités de réparation décliné à
notre quotidien c'est à dire qu'on voit
aujourd'hui que ce que le crime les
conséquences du crime ont donc un impact
sur notre quotidien
sur le plan économique sur le plan
agricole
parce que quand on regarde la question
de l'accès à la terre pour nos jeunes
agriculteurs la question de la pollution
la question environnementale la question
du chlordécone donc tout ça intègre bien
ce sont des questions liées aux
réparations
alors justement cette idée de la
réparation pendant longtemps gamme de
produits va certains ont compris de
bonne foi ou de mauvaise foi évidemment
que il s'agissait de verser de l'argent
aux lointains descendants des esclaves
je rappelle que la loi taubira dont vous
faisiez vous faisait l'écho tout à
l'heure elle porte le nom de la députée
de guyane d'alors et qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité de l'assemblée nationale le
21 et enfin plus exactement le 10 mai
2001 mais promulguée et publiée au
journal officiel le 21 mai de cette
année-là faisons de la france d'ailleurs
le premier état où mon à reconnaître que
la traite négrière et l'esclavagé des
d'afrique on constitue des crimes
contre l'humanité depuis la france a été
imitée par d'autres pays même
partiellement le bénin et le sénégal en
afrique de l'ouest mais c'est à peu près
tout même si beaucoup d'initiatives de
dirigeants politiques d'afrique des
caraïbes d'amérique barack obama par
exemple montre que cette idée fait son
chemin
donc ma question est précise et réparer
croit déjà un crime
certes mais un crime ne peut pas être et
temps et quels qu'ils soient donc comme
on fait comprendre qu'il s'agit de fait
réparer plus exactement les conséquences
néfastes traumatique de cette situation
historique
alors justement c'est le travail du cnr
parce que c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent
les personnes pensent que quand on parle
de réparation qu'il s'agit de donner 20
euros à chacun d'entre nous et c et puis
que ce sera réglé que ce sera réglé
mais ce n'est pas qu'une question je ne
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas qu'on ne peut pas
demander des indemnités
mais ce n'est pas qu'une question de
pécuniaire c'est aussi la réparation
foncière à dire que comme myriam le
disais tout à l'heure qui qui est
d'ailleurs qui a été indemnisée
ce sont les propriétaires d'esclaves qui
ont été indemnisées au moment de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
donc qui allaitaient qui a le le le les
finances sont les espoirs on leur a dit
vous êtes libérés et puis ils vont
retrouver lapidation vous retournez à
l'habitation parce que de toutes les
manières vous n'avez aucun moyen
d'existence donc bon on est on est
rentré dans une autre une autre logique
de l'habitation qui continue qui perdure
jusqu'à présent puisque les gens voient
bien et puis il y a tout le côté
psychologique tout le côté psychologique
les gens sont impactés pan pan pan se
passait et il y a deux ans lors de du
professeur charles nicolas on a bien vu
il y avait des scientifiques qui sont
venus de plusieurs pays justement où
vivent des infos descendants et on a
bien vu que l'impact est extraordinaire
et que c'est quelque chose aussi qui
fait partie des réparations parce que il
y a avant tout sous ce côté santé et
réparation va dire aux connexions avec
avec soi même
tu as dit que les réparations ces dates
sont d'abord des réparations à vis de
nous mêmes avec nous mêmes parce qu'on
voit bien que l'état l'état de la
société actuellement on voit bien qu'il
ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
réagir une phrase d'un article d'un
historien guadeloupéen georges prison je
ne sais pas si vous le connaissez qui
est sexe rumeurs récemment en octobre
dernier sur cette question en disant que
entre autres la demande en réparation
d'esclavagé est en fait une réponse à un
problème politique liée à des situations
d'injustice raciale vécue par des
descendants d'esclaves et de coloniser
vous arrivez à cette analyse
oui tout à fait donc donc without et pas
uniquement politique parce que en fait
c'est un peu parce qu'il faut rappeler
que le mérite engagé depuis 2005 dans
une procédure juridique procès contre
l'état français demande réparation et
c'est un peu en fait ce que nous
regrettons que les pasteurs que la mise
en place de politiques publiques
ben c'est au niveau des politiques
publiques que les choses pourront se
régler mais que ben des des
responsabilités des condamnations et
tout ça ne pourront pas être faite par
rapport à ce crime donc voilà j'ai
plusieurs tribunaux ont déjà statué sur
sa y en a tant pour le mois de juillet
2018 un arrêt d'une décision du tribunal
correctionnel de pointe-à-pitre puisque
l'utah français a été une nouvelle fois
a signé pour la deuxième fois nous prend
deux ans par une citoyenne ghosn au pn
est isolé si je puis dire et on attend
la réponse du tribunal à ce sujet mais
on s'attend aussi à ce que le tribunal
déboute cette plaignante comme ça a été
le cas la nuit enfin ça c'est ce que
l'état ne peut pas condamner puisqu'il
n'ya aucune loi qui pourrait voir la
condamnation des descendants
d'esclavagistes c'est pas la loi taubira
et puis de toute façon le crime est et
six anciens si vieux dans le temps que
il est difficile de mesurer son
préjudice en tout cas c'est ce même les
tribunaux disons c'est ça mais nous
avocats leur époque
il s'agit d'un crime contre l'humanité
ont donc contre l'humanité et
imprescriptible de 1945 depuis les
criminels de guerre
voilà ça prouve encore une fois qu'on
nous ait un déni de notre humanité à
travers ses décisions prises par les
tribunaux français
alors pour revenir à l'aspect de la
réparation
je ne sais pas comment me disait madame
privat tout à l'heure de donner 20 euros
comme ça chacun aux afro descendants
dizaines ou centaines de millions d'afro
descendants de par le monde et en
afrique et aux amériques asie amérique
s'est cependant dit oui évidemment qu'il
faut pas oublier il ya des réparations
d'ordre symbolique
il ya des réparations dont j'allais dire
en plus ils osent offic qui sont
revendiquées qui sont demandés à savoir
par exemple l'inscription des programmes
dans les programmes d'histoire les
manuels scolaires de l'issan de la
colonisation et de l'esclavagé par
exemple le fait qu' il faut les
faillites et pied à pied contre le
racisme contre les noirs qu'ils vivent
en dans leur pays d'origine où qu'ils
vivent en europe on a une résurgence du
racisme que ce soit en france ou en
europe de l'ouest aujourd'hui qui est
assez inquiétante donc finalement ce
thème de la réparation c'est un puits
sans fond d'un puit sans fond non non ça
n'arrête pas le combat n'a jamais arrêté
dans ces conditions c'est sûr que le
gros travail à faire à mon sens le
premier travail à faire c'est le travail
d'éducation
c'est à dire faire à l'école connaître
notre histoire connaître l'histoire
cette histoire aussi douloureuse soit
elle l'histoire de l'exclavage mais
aussi l'histoire de l'afrique c'est à
dire l'histoire de nos ancêtres parce
que tout cet anti là qui est occultée
par justement l'éducation nationale mais
ça fait du temps justement notre
jeunesse parce que nous ne l'est nous
voyons bien que les gens ignorent
parfois on est un petit peu ahuri
d'entendre par exemple des personnes
surtout au moment de
du convoi lorsque nous faisons des
émissions un tel appel dit mais je ne
savais pas que j'étais j'étais
descendante et afro descendantes
alors on lui demande me tuer quelle est
la couleur de ta peau avec moi sommes
bien nous aimons bien nous aimer il
personne n'a jamais dit moins que cette
mouette esclave afrique chez pardon donc
ça prouve bien que il ya un problème et
que ce problème là déjà à la base il ya
un travail à faire au niveau de
l'éducation nationale et le sénat il ya
deux ans lors de du lancement de la
décennie internationale des personnes
d'ascendance africaine nous avions
interpellé aussi bien le recteur à
l'époque que tu es madame bientôt
l'avenir est aussi la présidente de
l'université et elles avaient toutes les
deux très bien compris lorsque nous
avions effectivement fait connaître la
résolution de l'onu et son contenu
j'avais bien compris qu'ils avaient un
travail et un fear là haut niveau dans
l'éducation nationale résolution parlez
vous pas ce qu'elle avait pu agir sur la
question vous paraît dont celle
instaurant une décennie en hommage aux
personnes afrodescendants saisissant
d'un temps qui a lieu de 2000 2024 nos
résolutions prises à l'initiative de
plusieurs pays du caricom et d'afrique
que ce soit en afrique de l'ouest
afrique de l'est également qu'ils
étaient portés notamment par le ministre
des affaires étrangères du swaziland qui
n'a pas une ba 106 vonn qui n'a pas
vraiment participé à la traite négrière
mais enfin aimé en france il ya rien qui
se fait sur sept durant cette décennie
en france en général chez nous ici mais
en france en général il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'initiatives concert des
collectivités ces politiques et
universitaires
la france est signataire en fait de
cette résolution une cette résolution de
l'onu et nous avons effectivement au
mieux ses nerfs lorsque
nous avons eu connaissance de cette
résolution donc nous nous sommes posé
des questions nous avons dit non
en lisant le document on voit bien que
c'était pas spécialement à des
associations de prendre ce bâton à ce
mais lorsque nous avons interpellé dans
ce que nous avons voulu faire le
lancement nous avons écrit à toutes les
composantes justement où à l'époque
c'était conseil mais c'était oui le
conseil régional puisque au moment des
promotions la préparation c'était encore
le conseil régional nous avions écrit au
conseil régional conseil général
et puis à toutes les animations aux
préfets et tout ça pour dire nous
souhaiterions justement qu'il y ait une
rencontre qu'il ya quelque chose qui
sont à fait concernant cette résolution
nous n'avons pas eu de réponse en tout
cas si réponse il ya eu c'était des
réponses négatives
donc nous avons décidé de prendre nous
mêmes le taureau par les cornes et nous
avons lancée nous avons fait une journée
à c'était le 16 janvier 2016 donc au
parc aimé césaire
donc nous avons fait ce lancement avec
d'ailleurs des invités est quelqu'un qui
était venue de l'onu va me demander ce
français mireille fanon l'artiste la
fille de france paris qui avait fait le
déplacement et d'autres d'autres invités
de la caraïbe est il d'ailleurs et c'est
à la suite de cela d'ailleurs que nous
avons vu le recteur etc
mais c'est nous moi aujourd'hui je
relance au nom du seigneur je réitère
cette demande auprès des autorités parce
que nous avons fait des programmes nous
avons monté un comité de pilotage ou
seulement pour pouvoir faire des actions
vers des projets nous ne sommes pas
aidés parce que il nous il faut des
moyens nous n'avons une petite
association nous sommes deux petites
associations nous n'avons pas les moyens
de fuir
et ce sont les états qui doivent lire et
par exemple au niveau de la caricom les
pays de la caricom ce sont des états
c'est pas comme nous et ils ont accepté
la caricom a accepté d'intégrer la
martinique dans dans le mécénat de la
caille les seniors avec la caille
communes les conseils mais mais mais
voilà mais ils savent bien
nous sommes une exception nous sommes
une exception parce que nous ne sommes
pas un état blanc sauveur est un état
souverain donc eux ils font ils font des
choses
ils sont aidés ils sont appuyés par leur
état et nous ici nous envoler les manier
ou peut pas dire qu'on fait quand même
mais on fait quand même on peut
comprendre en fer peut comprendre on
peut expliquer que l'état français soit
un peu gêné aux entournures puisqu'on
sait bien qu'il ya beaucoup de
responsables politiques français
merde villes qui ont vécu qu'ils ont et
qui ont motivé bénéficié de l'attrait du
commerce colonial comme nantes la
rochelle bordeaux dunkerque qui ont du
mal à parler l'ancien maire de nantes
jean marc ayrault qui a été premier
ministre a reconnu et qui a donné
beaucoup de moyens les associations
jours avant le mémorial ascq deûle en
fête etc
mais bon le maire de bordeaux l'actuel
les juppé l'ancien jacques chaban delmas
ne voulait absolument pas entendre
parler de quelques réparations que ce
soit et jusqu'à présent des militants on
porte fermée à la mairie de bordeaux
pour évoquer ces questions là bon donc
ça peut se comprendre mais ici en
martinique la région le département
enfin anciennement aujourd'hui c'est m
dr les partis politiques des gens qui
disent qu'ils sont pour l'indépendance
qui sont pour l'autonomie alors moi je
pour ben je parle pour le mieux puisque
lors du convoi donc on sollicite la
mairie ainsi que l'école toutes les
collectivités qui nous aider et c'est
vrai que en retour bon il ya très
quelques communes parfois de très
petites communes qui nous aident et les
plus grosses bon est ce à dire que voilà
que ben ça n'intéresse pas les gens où
je vous qui savez pas compris peut-être
peut-être quand même par exemple la
municipalité de fort de france en 2016
nous a aidés on va dire ils ont mis à
disposition ce à dire qu'ils ne sont pas
opposé de refus
donc on peut considérer que bon on a un
fait un partenariat avec eux ils nous
ont un traité leur espace et c'est pour
qu'on puisse faire d'ailleurs le
meilleur de fort de france
c est même venu à cette manifestation
donc bon on peut dire que c'est un
encouragement mais je veux dire que
c'est pratiquement l'exception
l'écriture mais les personnes qui
décident à épi qui détiennent les décors
de la bourse
est ce que le nouveau préfet n'est pas
peut-être sensibiliser à ce genre de
questions il ya massa s'est jamais
faudrait peut-être les autorités les
formations politiques les collectivités
certes mais la population est ce que
vous avez c'est moins que le convoi à un
certain succès il ya plusieurs dizaines
voire plusieurs centaines de personnes
selon les étapes puisqu'il se déroule
sur une période assez longue qui
participe concrètement réellement
physiquement puisqu'il faut marcher
pendant longtemps de nuit c'est pas
facile alors s'y pose quand même des
efforts mais est ce que la population
est ce que vous sentez un engouement
intérêt auprès des gens dans la rue
autour de vous dans votre famille votre
voisinage dans vos milieux
professionnels pour ces questions moi je
dirais oui oui j'ai dit oui puisque une
fois qu'on commence à décliner en fait
la question des réparations chaque
personne soit sur le plan social
culturel ou encore sur le plan de la
santé ou quoi chaque bain on retrouve
wii trouvent un intérêt à la question
mais parler de réparation dont de
manière très global it soit mais de
toute façon lemire dit que la réparation
elle et elle est globale de toute façon
les politiques économiques morales
sociales culturelles et spirituelles
donc c'est ce fait à tous les plans et
il s'est un peu ce que madame privat 10
est en fait la question si de historique
est fondamentale pourquoi parce que ça
rejoint la question devant les estime de
soi parce que pour que nos jeunes
puissent mieux en fait s'ancrer dans
leur environnement et puisse accepter
comme ils sont dans leur bassin caribéen
en martinique avec des racines c'est
vrai diverses
il faut qu'ils aient une connaissance
globale de leur histoire mais on voit
que ben qu'à l'école il ya une histoire
qui est un peu biaisé une histoire
formaté qui leur est et qui leur est
donnée et s'ils ne vont pas la recherche
sinon pas parfois des parents qui
encadrent qui encadrent et qui leur
portent l'information d'un mais qu'est
ce qui empêche les professeurs
d'histoire aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui les
empêche de dalé dalle certains manuels
puisqu'il y en a dans lequel il y a des
pages les chapitres consacrés à
l'histoire coloniale au sens large
ou alors de faire leurs recherches et
même pour proposer ses documents ses
réflexions à leurs élèves parce qu'il ya
encore des réticences associé me suis
parti c'est très bien de souligner ce
ce problème est de voir comme ça parce
que en fait à l'éducation nationale je
pense je pensais je ne sais pas si c'est
pas un manque de courage je pense qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment d'enseignants qui
font ce travail justement au niveau 10
de leurs élèves et je pense que il y a
aussi une forme de sanction une forme de
il y à il ya des personnels je pas cité
de d'établissement il y à des personnes
qui sont justement sur cette dynamique
de d'enseigner l'histoire d'enseignés
l'afrique d'enseignés l'esclave âge et
ce sont des personnes qui se retrouvent
avec des problèmes de avec la hiérarchie
avec les parents pour sens kantien des
anciens soutiens son soutien des
collègues parce qu'on leur dit que il
parle trop de ça donc c'est moi je
trouve ça très grave
le christ jusqu'à préciser il ya des
instructions officielles c'est à dire
émanant du ministère de l'éducation
nationale depuis la loi taubira incitant
les enseignants à se former et donc à
former leurs élèves incitant les
éditeurs de manuels scolaires et les
auteurs de manuels scolaires à inclure
l'histoire la géographie de toutes les
régions de france qui ont été victimes
aux bénéficiaires du commerce colonial
donc qu'il n'y a pas de raison que vais
temps après on s'en veut trente ans
après quasiment on se bat encore un beau
chassé ou soupçonnés de déformer les
esprits de nos chiens et nos chats mâles
ça ben ça existe parce qu'on a des
exemples concrets
malheureusement dont et
ça existe mais c'est vrai que comme vous
dites
ben rien n'empêche à nous enseignants de
le faire donc à eux de s'organiser
c'est ça aussi cette auto réparations
dont on parle au mieux il faut que ça
que cette réparation ne prendra forme
que si nous nous organisons pour aller
vers notre auto réparation donc voilà
donc c'est dans cette dynamique que nous
sommes et nous invite en fait
effectivement les enseignants qui sont
dans une dynamique de vouloir enseigner
l'histoire liée à notre environnement
lié à l'esclavagé liés à l'afrique
alors élève à s'organiser soit se
rapprocher du cnr nous constituer des
commissions
voilà nous sommes là face à la première
matinée que la première radio avec
aujourd'hui gabriel privat vice
présidente du conseil national pour les
réparations ses nerfs et myriam martin
militante de cette organisation pour
parler justement de la thématique de la
réparation dont on a beaucoup parlé
durant toute cette année qui est celle
du 170e anniversaire de l'interdiction
de l'esclavagé dans les colonies
françaises
en tout cas tout à l'heure nous parlions
des soutiens ou pas que vous avez des
autorités locales au central l'évêché
l'église en martinique que l'église
catholique en particulier a eu un très
bon point donc contribuer à la
construction de notre société jusqu'à
nos jours l'église qui pendant longtemps
enfin le clergé qui pendant longtemps
s'est accommodé de la traiter miel et de
l' esclavage avant que certains se
révoltent en ayant payé cet engagement
d'ailleurs de leur carrière puisque
beaucoup de prêtres en utilisant les
résistants étaient expulsés ou en tout
cas on était dissuader de rester sur
place aujourd'hui à une tentative de
réhabilitation de la part de l'actuel
évêque de martinez conseiller en matière
de ces ecclésiastiques
mais où est ce que l'évêché vous
écoutait ce que vous avez fait une
démarche auprès de monseigneur marqueur
de son équipe pour justement que
l'église contribue à propager son
message de l'auto réparation de la
réhabilitation de notre être collectif
alors je vais commencer il me revient
pas terminée le président de mire ligne
du cnr d'ailleurs avait il ya 2 ou 3 ans
contactez justement le moment où il est
arrivé où nos seniors mackey a pris ses
fonctions il lui avait demandé un
entretien
bon je ne sais pas il n'en est pas
ressortie effectivement grand chose mais
il a expliqué il fallait bien expliquer
la position du mieux la position du
sénat bon maintenant je vois que
effectivement c'est un jeune qu'il fait
ils font des choses et cetera mais est
ce que c'est vraiment dans le sens de
nos réparation dans le sens dans la
philosophie dans l'idéologie de ce que
nous faisons je laisse myriam oui mais
j'avais faim oui alors oui donc je
complète en fait il le prix d'un bien
rencontré mon seigneur michael est en
fait il avait parlé effectivement de
réparation est également d'écologie
bleus se sont plus rencontrés sur la
question de l'écologie
et voilà et les la question des
réparations
on voit que effectivement l'église
s'empare de cette question là mais on
voit qu'ils tendent à parler de
réconciliation réparatrice alors que
nous ce que nous disons au mit on parle
de réparation des conciliatrice c'est à
dire que c'est la philosophie des 3r sai
en reconnaissance du crime d'accord
réparation puis réconciliation y aura
réconciliation des lans qu'il y aura
réparation de conciliation truc la
réconciliation entre les descendants
d'esclaves et descendants de colons qui
ont commis en fait la chronique
mais est ce que ces choses ne sont pas
si on va revenir sur sa philosophie la
thématique des 3e et il y a eu des
anciens esclaves qui a franchi ou
émancipé on était propriétaire
d'esclaves eux mêmes avant l'abolition
de l'esclavagé ici ou ailleurs et il y a
eu des hommes de couler en libre
autrement dit nul art comme on dit
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient des esclaves
domestiques jusque là où des chants des
esclaves dans leur entourage donc est-ce
que c'est aussi clair c'est blanc ou
noir en face un jeu évidemment est-ce
que c'est aussi simple que ça de vouloir
est considéré aujourd'hui un siècle et
demi après l'abolition esclavage ceux
qui descendent des uns et des autres
sachant qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
confusion un certain moment oui mais il
faut déjà reconnaître ses confirme ce
fait remettre à plat sur la table ces
confusions et voir comment ben on peut
réparer justement ces confusions comment
on peut faire en sorte que ben ben les
inégalités qui ont été criés puisse d'un
s'effacer ou voilà donc c'est ça c'est
c'est la logique d'un la gaine ça alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
l'autre mandat d'amqui 20 la philosophie
sexe comme ça que vous l'appelez des 3r
réparation allons réhabiliter
considérait alors c'est la
reconnaissance reconnaissance
reconnaissance du crime dont ça ça a
aidé été fait oui il ya beaucoup de gens
qui on sent qu'ils sont encore réticents
en disant que mais non c'est l esclavage
votre mode de vie
le système mécanique d'organisation de
la société donc on n'a pas reconnaître
un crime quand tout le monde le
pratiquer si je puis dire pour résumer
alors deuxième
le deuxième r ces réparations ce que
l'on nous refuse ce que l'état français
refuse aujourd'hui au aux personnes
d'ascendance africaine
voilà donc réparation des réparations
global sur le plan politique social
culturel économique spirituel et puis
donc dans cette question des réparations
est aussi l'auto réparation citoyen que
nous mêmes nous
devons nous organiser pour pouvoir
tendre vers cancun où nous en sommes
encore loin
voilà c'est difficile et puis la
considération
en fait c'est c'est comme tout instant
qu'il n'y a pas de justice y aura pas de
paix c'est ça c'est un principe
en fait c'est un principe reste un
principe juridique
oui qu'on applique dans certains pays
koné qui a été appliquée aux usa mon
afrique du sud par exemple avec le vieux
des commissions vérité et réconciliation
mais même si bon on a vu que ça n'a pas
souhaité filmer alors juste quand est-ce
qu'on avait besoin d'un besoin de ça
aujourd'hui parce que les descendants
des colons aujourd'hui mardi qu'ils sont
minoritaires du point de vue
démographique du point de vue du
numérique et d'une part et puis d'autre
part bon ils sont de plus en plus dilué
dans l'espace économique que est ce que
il ya eu même atteint 200 d'après vous
d'après ce que vous en savez ce sont des
martiniquais comme nous même temps fort
puisque nous mêmes ce qu'ils disent ok
pourquoi pas mais non si on veut dire
que les descendants des colons les
descendants des esclaves ou les
lointains mais nous vivons sur le même
territoire nous n'offrirons temps
quasiment tous les jours est-ce que j'en
fais partie oui parce que beaucoup de
descendants des colons sont des chefs
d'entreprise ou des cas où une
entreprise dont ils sont les
martiniquais qui font des barthes une
grille oui je ne dis pas qu'ils sont les
seuls de toutes les manières un système
économique qui maintenant comme je le
disais tout à l'heure ils sont ils ont
toujours été minoritaire d'accord au
niveau de l' esclavage
c'étaient les colons c'était une poignée
de personnes par rapport au nombre
d'africains qui venait
et équité dans les colonies et
d'ailleurs on a souvent tendance à
croire que les africains sont restés là
comme ça sans rien faire en attendant
une abolition et c'est alors qu'a eu des
révoltes qui a eu des échanges vifs les
résistances dans tous les coins de la
martinique est d'ailleurs contre contre
six colons bon maintenant il
ils détiennent quand même un certain
nombre de levier on va dire économique
et tout ça et puis il ya une espèce de
la pression de pression morale y
persistent sur les gens macally travail
babicz a même quand il est fabriqué et
cetera monde du travail bit et à l'ail
tout et où quand même on voit qu'il y à
une pression qui est exercée qu'on le
veuille ou non on la sent on la ressent
quand on discute avec les gens
il ya une pression son bouquet oui
chaque match et je pense mais je sais
pas quand vous dites que qui se
mélangent oui sur le plan mental on est
content d'y retourner dès maintenant les
descendants des colons
oui n'est ce pas comme étant forcément
des descendants des colons quand même
mais on a bien diverti geek ça ne me
connaissent pas oui l'homme et en
descendant d'arthur et non mais ils
bénéficient quand même davantage issue
système esclavagiste puisque il ya eu ce
dédommagement dont vous avez très bien
pas une fois dans vous d'une de vos
chroniques
il bénéficiait dans le décret alors là
vous aurez aujourd'hui un becquet de
votre âge de votre génération nuit à mal
ça puisque vous êtes parmi les jeunes
générations
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie qu'ils
vous disent qu'est-ce que vous avez un
truc que vous lui disiez pour que vous
soyez
comment dirais je connais l'idée nous
est égal corps comme on dit c'est en
français comme
sénégal selon que vous soyez sur un pied
d'égalité intellectuel et culturel
mais pour moi nous sommes sur un même
pied d'égalité parce que moi je n'ai je
me sens pas inférieur à lui déjà
donc ça c'est réglé et en fait je
n'attends en fait que jonathan lui
je n'attends rien des questions moins ce
que je veux que l'état en fait reconnaît
ce jusqu'à c'est c'est l'étape aussi qui
a qui a organisé ce système
reconnaissent qu'il ya une inégalité qui
était fait à un moment donné et qu'il
faut réparer cette inégalité c'est tout
mais moi je n'attends rien de neuf et
que je n'exige rien d'un becquet au
journal est d'ailleurs s'ils sont prêts
à venir demain qu'on voit ben oui
pourquoi pas on convoi pour les
réparations et très bien comme s'est
jamais produit ça s'est pas produit mais
normalement à certains moments comme je
fais je fais le convoi parce que j'y
participe chaque année je me dis parfois
c'est dur je suis partie parfois mon
rythme et je me dis mais innocent dit
c'est nous qui a fait pénitence ccb
thierry teuhpu faire équipe qu'à bouffer
manche s'est pas posée par nourgeek nous
la casse ou fake à machelen 8 tous assez
mou l'homme bien kamanyola c'est vrai
que c'est c'est symbolique cette marche
là mais parfois on se dit mais c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible de ce
système quand ce serait vous de marché
dans ce convoi pour la réparation chaque
année quand ça comme ça qu'on va t-il
finir quand pour être aura-t-il plus de
raison d'être et gamal sa coquette
encore aux jeunes dit nous il n'aura
plus de raison d'être comme coach et on
l'aimé pas c'est comme quand tu réalises
cette réconciliation sky réparation et
qu'on un livre à cette réconciliation
c'est-à-dire qu'on vivra dans un monde
apaisé apaisé bon c'est vrai il est plus
juste
alors vous disiez que l'état doit
reconnaître comment dirais-je sa
participation sans sa contribution à ce
crime et là il ya aucun enseignant le
législatif qui leur permettra en tout
cas en france et surtout pas la loi
taubira qui n'est pas une loin de
contraintes
c'est une loi déclaratives qui n'ouvrent
pas la voie à des actions en justice
selon les mots de l'historienne une
williams n'aurait elle il ya matière ce
jeu-là site de générique s qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la question
jusqu'à aujourd'hui que vous connaissez
bien évidemment et donc on est nous
sommes un peu gêné les citoyens les
associations d'aujourd'hui pour traîner
l'état devant des tribunaux puisqu'il ya
pas de loi qui permet une sanction
quelle qu'elle soit à ce sujet mais non
mais bon ça n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord et que ça parce que une noix
pour nous parce qu'on nous dit que la
loi elle et mémorielle oui or une loi
n'y portée normative toute loi stack la
définition l'essence même d'une loi
c'est énorme
donc et ben aujourd'hui donc pas
aujourd'hui en 2005 lemire a porté
plainte et a incité d'autres
martiniquais a porté plainte à ses côtés
donc une quarantaine de deux
martiniquais y voient même plus qui ont
porté plainte et donc les choses suivent
leur cours en fait là on arrive à la
cour de cassation puisque l'objectif
c'est d'aller aux plus hautes instances
et de faire en sorte que cette affaire
aille au niveau international alors en
parlant d'un niveau international de la
caricom des pays du marché commun de la
caraïbe
les anciennes colonies britanniques pour
aller très vite même s'il n'ya pas que
ça brille les highlights you need you
win amis qui sont dans la caricom
également même si marc tsinghua
d'oublier ils sont encore nombreux
observateurs ils ont été longtemps au
titre de la france donc en septembre
2013 une vaste campagne a été menée
visant les anciennes puissances
coloniales la france des pays bas le
royaume uni la grande-bretagne l'espagne
le portugal mais également la norvège la
suède et le danois
on veut déposer deux possessions
coloniales ici en assignant s'est éteint
pour demander réparation des préjudices
causés par les conséquences de
l'esclavagé de la colonisation dans un
contexte politique relativement
favorable depuis une trentaine d'années
à ces questionnements bon mais nous on
n'a retenu que nous avons pas vraiment
conscience ou connaissance de cette
campagne puisqu'il ya eu déjà des
actions fortes exemple caricom il y à 18
mois a mandaté un cabinet d'avocats
orrick un londres pour assigner la
grande bretagne devant des tribunaux
britanniques et l'un depuis quelques
semaines ya tout un débat à ce sujet
parce que des tribunaux britanniques
estiment que l'état britannique a des
responsabilités et donc doit en quelque
sorte faire face à ses responsabilités
gabriel oui oui ça fait effectivement
c'est d'ailleurs depuis 2013 que la
caricom a institué les cnr et que ayant
participé justement 1,7 à une de ces
réunions à saint vincent le cnr de la
martinique a été créée donc en novembre
2013 en novembre 2013 et donc c'est vrai
que ils sont ils ont fait ils font des
actions donc les pays de pays de la
caraïbe mène ces actions là et nous on
en entend parler parce que justement
nous sommes nous faisons pas anti du du
cnr et de la caricom
mais nous avons justement l'intention au
cnr de faire une lettre à destination du
public pour les informer parce que bon
c'est toutes ces informations à nourrir
au second plus en anglais donc il faut
traduire et serra et nous nous sommes
dit à la dernière assemblée générale du
magma ce 4 mars que il fallait
absolument que les gens sachent ce qui
se passe parce que parfois on a
l'impression que autour de nous les gens
croient que nous sommes les seuls là une
bande d'illuminés des jongles mire et
cetera qui mange qui marche comme des
fous le soir pendant une semaine
et puis qui attaquent l'état qui
demandait réparation et alors que nonce
à bouillir ya dedans il ya ça bouillonne
ça bouillonne et de partout elle traduit
comme même là maintenant au niveau des
pays d'afrique les voix s'élèvent un pur
pour changer les choses et pour de bon
jeudi remettre les anciens colons pour
réunifier une afrique
autour d'eux des africains d'accord
parce que c'est c'est économiquement et
supportable de venger son vin de qualité
de ma question est ce que nous
martinique et en guadeloupe un ces dames
ancienne colonie française
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas en retard
par rapport à la marche du monde parce
que nous avons parlé de la caraïbe
caricom qui est très en pointe sur la
question qui régulièrement chaque année
effet une interpellation devant
l'assemblée générale de l'onu à new york
et non mais nous avons quand même été
d'aider et le curseur justement le
premier l'état le premier temps premier
rang dans les régions flamande et
injustement par l'intermédiaire du mir a
porté cette affaire devant devant la
justice c'est à dire à porter plainte
contre l'état on a été les premiers et
il faut pas oublier que justement chaque
année au moment du convoi les nous avons
des invités de la caraïbe
donc nous nous échangeons avec eux donc
ils sont informés ils sont ils sont très
attentifs à ce qui se passe au niveau de
la justice au niveau de ce qu ils ont
des échanges fructueux avec nos avocats
donc ce n'est pas étranger du tout et je
signale même qu'en 2015
nous étions invités à new york et à new
york nous l'avons rencontrée justement
sur elive école qui est donc changé au
niveau de la caille brûle la caille
comme pour les réparations et donc il ya
eu il ya eu des échanges avec nos
avocats non je pense pas nous sommes pas
derrière maintenant au ses 20 ans au
niveau de la population même et je suis
un petit peu
comment dirais-je déçu déçu tout en
sachant que l'idée progresse je vois
quand même que au niveau du convoi et
tout ça bon les gens en sang ne sont pas
on a l'impression que ça avance et en
même temps que l'on piétine
parce que ne serait ce qu'au vu du
nombre de personnes qui pratiquent un
fait qui qui qui se déplace au convoi
mort ya des moments où on se dit mais on
devrait avoir plus de personnes que ça
et ne serait ce que pour les colloques
chaque année pour les colloques ont fait
venir des sommités internationales et
c'est vrai que c'est un gros moment un
grand moment où il ya du monde qui vient
assister écouter etc
l'année dernière justement là la dame
madame bello c'est clair c'est elle qui
s'occupe justement de cette préparation
du convoi
car ces dégâts c'est vrai que
lorsqu'elle est elle est venue est
présente elle a aussi présenté un livre
dans lequel il ya un appel à la jeunesse
africaine et afro descendantes a
injustement celui de roi bélie s'unir
contre ce système qui nous aux qui
continue de nous opprimer de de toutes
les manières il y avait du monde il y
avait du monde mais je vous assure qu'il
ya il ya eu des des sommités où j'ai été
interpelé je me suis dit mais pourquoi
nous sommes si peu nombreux la peut-être
que nous allons maintenant nous faisons
chaque fois notre un grand voilà nous
disons mais pourquoi il ya si peu de
monde ne comprend pas il reste deux
minutes émission vous venez de citer la
dame m'a pris 20
hilary bacon ce qui est sociologue
barbadien natif de verbier qui est
vice-président de la university of the
west indies l'actuel vice-président et
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
questions
en matière sociologique matière
historique sur les conséquences de la
colonisation dans la caraïbe et dans
l'amérique des plantations et qui invite
un peu partout pour vous faire état de
ces recherches qui n'a pas encore été
invité à paris et encore moi ça fort de
france alors qu'est ce que vous attendez
mais il est musulman alors est ce que
justement lui c'est l'une des figures de
proue jeener il y en a plusieurs autres
le premier mise de saint kitts nevis par
exemple de 500 dockers déjà qu'ils
s'impliquent des politiques des
intellectuels écrivains des artistes
mais nous on a l'impression qu'on est un
peu timide encore est-ce que vous avez
bon espoir que dans l'année qui vient
puisque nous sommes dans la 70e
anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé que les choses peuvent
encore évoluer
il ya mal ça oui la fin de l'émission
oui oui je gardais ce pas que les choses
évolueront et que les artistes de toutes
façons s'imprègne de cette question et
qu'il babin produisent autour de cette
question y en a un qui est que l'on a
honoré lors d'un convoi en 2016 je crois
voilà et puis sinon je finis pour dire
que ben le convoi au sénégal donc on
s'en va le 23 avril
on est au sénégal donc jusqu'au 2 mai il
s'agit donc d'une
de voyages leur connexion avec la
terre-mère donc il y aura quatre temps
forts un premier enfant qui sera un
colloque sur crimes contre l'humanité et
réparation et là aussi donc on aura des
sommités présente on aura un professeur
biyogo donc il y aura également le
recteur de l'université de dschang anta
diop de dakar et tout ça il y aura
également nos avocats de martinique qui
viendront parler de leur expertise sur
la question des réparations et donc
après deuxième temps fort donc le convoi
à proprement parler on va faire une
marche dans gorée et puis troisième
temps fort donc là il s'agit d'une
journée de reconnexion dans un centre de
promotion des plantes médicinales qui
est mené par donc le docteur eric bobo
dessous et puis le 4ème temps enfants
c'est une journée de retrouvailles ce
temps faire en sorte qu'ils adhèrent
connexions culturelles artisanales
économique entre les personnes qui
seraient du voyage
tout un programme sur lequel nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir si vous ne rendent
évidemment merci mais yamal ça et
gabriel primagaz du conseil national des
décorations d'être venu nous parler
aujourd'hui de la réparation du crime
des crimes de l'esclavagé
pourquoi comment et quand c'était une
émission aujourd'hui réalisé par
jean-louis bongo merci de votre
attention à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]